I used to get picked on so much all the
time every grade for my ears being
Chinese
crying about it all the time like not
your ears though oh dude 100 okay check
this out a lot of times wherever I went
I was like one of the only Asian kids my
first like week in high school obviously
my ears are [ __ ] up now but they were
just really big when I was come on dude
I was walking around campus and these
dudes came up I didn't know them and
they were like yo what the [ __ ] oh my
God damn look at the smooth ears yo oh
I thought they were my [ __ ] friends
for a sec and then they were like ah and
they just left but eventually you
realize like look bro there's nothing
you can do about it you start cracking
jokes back or you just realize like hey
don't take yourself too seriously
because everyone's gonna [ __ ] dunk on
you anyway these guys are kind of like
gangsters bro so I was like yeah my ears
are [ __ ] big you eventually have a
good sense of humor about it because
there's nothing else you could do about
it getting cauliflower ear was a good
choice